foreign
event Council usually receives around a
thousand calls that require action or
further investigation there are multiple
or close weather events this can create
a backlog Council will triage the
service calls and respond to the most
urgent ones first people can normally
expect a response from Council staff
within a couple of weeks however
sometimes it can take months to work
through that volume of requests where
decision is made to carry out remedial
or mitigation works this will either be
carried out in that same Financial year
or budgeted in the council's annual plan
or long-term plan for carrying out in
future years
please use the council website keep
yourself updated on progress and
projects
foreign
[Music]